brexit isn't a done deal yet that's the
battlecry of a band of remains refusing
to give up the fight against the UK
leaving the EU their leader something of
an unexpected figure an infrastructure
expert and Labour Lord who's taken to
Tooting the country as well as picking a
few fights on Twitter as well
Lord Adonis joins me now in the studio
lovely to see you morning explain to me
the purpose of this this grand to offer
for want of a better phrase that you've
been on you've been tuning the country
speaking to people trying to persuade
them off more well plexus is not a done
deal Parliament has not yet decided that
we're leaving the European Union there
were negotiations taking place the Prime
Minister is conducting those she will
bring a deal back at the end of the year
and then Parliament needs to decide what
I think is absolutely vital between now
and then is that we get to grips with
the big crisis that is indeed facing the
country a crisis education health
housing a real sense of alienation in
large parts of the country which is
fairly clear to me is what played a big
part in the brexit vote two years ago
and it's it's extremely important to
hear that at firsthand so I'm visiting
all of the places that voted most
heavily to leave the European Union two
years ago and talking to people it's get
a sense of what's really happening and
what the message I'm picking up is that
there is real concern about what's going
on in the country people's living
standards have been falling they think
the public service is in a bad state
a lot of these communities are
disintegrating but Brussels and getting
out of the European Union is not the
answer the answer is better policies at
home and in particular and end to
austerity and much more constructive
policies when it comes to performing the
NHS improving education and in
particular opportunities for young
people because young people in our
society who don't go on to university at
the moment get an extremely raw deal and
we need to put that light so I said
let's just start with with almost the
first thing that you said there that
Parliament has not yet decided that the
UK should leave the European Union know
that that is a debatable point at the
same time surely the British public has
decided that we are leaving the European
Union the manner in which we leave is a
matter for debate but the fact is we are
to come out the European Union that's
what people voted for that's not the
case at all what happened two years ago
was a vote on whether or not we wanted
the government to start the process of
negotiating leaving the European Union
but nobody could see the terms we had no
idea what's gonna happen to our trade
what's gonna happen to the whole future
of our organization terms of security
all of these big issues that matter
wasn't that an argument though better
better made before the question was
drafted into the people well the idea
that you know the the the the referendum
vote that we had did anything other than
give the government that the approval of
the people to take us out the European
Union or otherwise seems to me to be the
case but in fact of course the people
couldn't approve a deal which didn't
exist and the key issue now is that the
government after the referendum lightly
started the process of negotiating to
leave the European Union they will
produce a deal when that deal is put to
Parliament by the prime minister at the
end of the year then we can see what's
going to happen so our trade you know
that 350 million a week which was
supposed to be going to the NHS does it
exist it's quite clear it doesn't just
an agonist or had during the referendum
campaign and we had a we had a vote at
the end of it people decided which case
they believed more remain leave no they
weren't Alchemy's head at the time
because we didn't know at the time what
was going to happen to the customs union
the single market to our trade so the
financial deal you know we had the 350
million a week for the NHS where it's
now clear we've got a thirty nine
billion exit fee and what I'm saying I
think the argument that is going to get
increasing traction over the next few
months is look you had a wish list two
years ago and people expressed a view on
that now we've got the actual terms
we're a democracy Parliament and in my
view British people should make a
judgement and where I'm critical of
parts of the media particularly the BBC
at the moment is they seem to be
regarding it as a done deal that we're
leaving at the European Union when it's
absolutely not a done deal at the moment
Parliament will take the final say it
can if it chooses to do so refer it to
the people we don't leave until next
March the biggest issue in British
politics at the moment is whether the
right thing to do when we see the terms
is to leave the European Union or as I
believe to have a big program of a form
at home to deal with the problems which
were afflicting the country but not to
scapegoat Europe and foreigners and bail
out of the EU I mean we will do with
that as you describe them the brexit
Broadcasting Corporation in a moment or
two but but it strikes me that I
according to the polling evidence the
majority of people in the UK including
those who voted to remain within the
European Union believe that the
referendum result means by necessity
that we come out of the European Union
it does strike me that perhaps you're
not exactly speaking to crowds of
thousands when you're tuning the country
well at the moment of course what's
happening is that Tresemme is
negotiating the terms so it doesn't
surprise me at all that the issue is off
the boil while there's negotiations take
place and they're very complicated
negotiations because of course they're
these trade issues and the whole
economic future the country is an
extremely complicated issue
similarly Ireland and the border in
Ireland whether there's going to be a
hard border or not which is a huge issue
for the future of the country that's
being negotiated at the moment what will
happen at the end of the year and this
is as it were all the build-up to it is
that Teresa make will produce her draft
treaty we will see what's going to
happen to our contributions the EU the
350 million for the NHS our trade the
border in Ireland we are a democracy the
right thing to happen then is for
Parliament and the British people to
make a judgment not based on the wish
list of two years ago but based on the
actual terms and that's what this is all
building up to over the next few months
come on don't you just think then the
British public got it wrong ultimately
you think that the majority of the
people that voted in that referendum
what a bit daft and voted the wrong way
except that at all
there's a two-part process to this the
first part was starting this process of
leaving on the basis that it might be a
good idea and that's what happened in
the referendum two years ago but you
know it's like buying a house when you
actually see the survey you see what is
that you know whether there is dry rot
or whether the roof doesn t fixing and
all of that you then make a judgment
based on the actual terms know what's
actually happening at the moment
essentially is that we're conducting the
survey on leaving the European Union and
the British people should make the final
say okay what is your problem with the
way in which the BBC is operated in the
past well since since March the 26th
you've you'd sent 44 tweets using the
hashtag brexit Broadcasting Corporation
at get old Fox reporting you've sent 72
tweets attacking the BBC this week alone
let's take a look just at one of the
mics they just is it for those urging me
to go quiet on the BBC it's important to
understand that brexit and Faraj are
largely the creation
of the BBC this isn't a cider ship at a
central issue if we're going to win next
year's final do you referendum to honor
our European destiny as a people the BBC
created Nigel Faraj come on the BBC gave
Faraj a platform he would otherwise not
have had 32 appearances on BBC question
time which is their flagship news and
current affairs programme 32 now over
you know because they created brick so
the BBC not the only four of course
there's lot of other things going on as
well but they largely did because of the
huge platform that they gave to Faraj
and to the whole brexit case but the
prominently we were given that more
people voted to leave the European Union
than remain within it doesn't that
suggest that perhaps the BBC were right
to have a plurality of voices on
discussion I'm not I'm not
of course objecting to a plurality of
voices I'm rejecting to the huge
prominence that they gave to Nigel Faraj
and his party over many years but were
in a situation were in now and my
complaint about the BBC which is is
shared now by hundreds of thousands and
I think probably millions of people
given the sentiment in the country is
that bricks it is not a done deal at the
moment the BBC said to me last week that
they had stopped reporting the choice
between leaving and not leaving because
they regarded it is now settled that is
not the case this issue will not be
settled until Parliament decides at the
end of the year whether on the basis of
tourism a treaty we aren't leaving
European Union now there the public
broadcaster they should and they have a
duty under their charter to be impartial
in the reporting of their news my view
is that they're not - my view is that
other public service particularly done
straight off can't I mean have they
ruled on there I mean maybe see in a
week it's all getting a little bit Paul
Masson isn't it it's the kind of you're
turning into the kind of a crazy or show
to your end of Twitter a lot it's very
important to understand what's going on
here if we're going to be moving towards
another expression of the popular will
on this which is what I believe will
happen I think that I either by
Parliament which of course will then
interact with the people or by
Parliament referring this to a
referendum there's going to be a big
process of public debate at the end of
the year on whether or not we leave the
European Union and what we cannot have
next time as we had last
is the BBC treating Nigel Faraj as the
voice of the country which is what
happened last time and giving him huge
prominence when he's the XX leader of a
party at two percent in the polls that's
the issue now my view is if the BBC
won't do its job as the public service
broadcaster then some of the funding it
has for news at the moment should go to
other public service broadcasters like
Channel 4 News which I think can
probably do a better job these are very
very big issues note the whole future of
millions of people in this country is
going to be determined by what happens
on brexit we deserve a proper debate in
the country and if the BBC won't do it
then other should have the opportunity
well your grant or no doubt continues
Lord of Darkness many thanks for being
with us